all right everybody welcome we've got
something a little different today we've
got a Sunday stream which I have not
done for a while and we have a Donald
Trump virtual town hall from the Lincoln
Memorial scheduled to start in about a
half hour about quarter past 7:00 p.m.
here on the east coast of 4:15 p.m. on
the west coast so we've got a little bit
of time to chat and get caught up before
that happens and when indeed it is time
for that we for the purposes of avoiding
copyright claims we are going to be
doing the actual Town Hall exclusively
on Twitch so we're on YouTube and
Facebook right now but closer to 7:15
here on the east will will pinch off
these other streams and be exclusively
over at twitch.tv slash David Pakman it
is usually a better way to avoid
copyright issues but we'll be here until
then welcome to everybody hope everybody
had a good weekend I just built a fruit
cage I'm going to be imprisoning my
fruits and vegetables because there are
squirrels and there are birds and I
don't I don't know what's getting them
rabbits but in any case we're going to
be imprisoning the fruits and vegetables
to try to keep animals out and keep
vegetables in and so I did that what
else did I do this weekend I went on a
socially distant walk with my mom and
you know just the neuro I went on a bike
ride normal stuff but we're getting
right back into it we've got a huge
program tomorrow one of the things I
will be covering tomorrow is Kaylee
McKenna nior Macan Annie's first press
briefing as Donald Trump's press
secretary check out what she promised
not to do during that straw press
briefing Friday
very instead of their a better sense of
what your plan is are you planning to do
these in a daily basis at this point and
also will you pledge never to lie to us
for that I will never lie to you you
have my word on that right now
unfortunately she lied endlessly during
this thing she claimed that the molar
report fully exonerated Donald Trump as
we know the molar report could not
exonerate Donald Trump on obstruction of
justice she said the molar report cost
the the Americans the Millar probe cost
the American people 30 million 40 minute
I don't know ignoring the fact that it
recovered more money than it cost very
very dishonest she you know on and on
and on just lie after lie so tomorrow
we'll go through all the lies that she
told promising not to lie and
immediately lying we also had over the
weekend a whole bunch of crazy crazy
stuff here's one protest in Arizona uh
it's crazy to even call it a protest but
here it is right so anyway my favorite
thing here is douchebags spelt Duke bag
or douche bag
you know I yeah anyway I don't have to
say too much about that I did put a
tweet out that you know Trump and
flunkies keep claiming we have a very
low death rate of course our death rate
is 14th highest in the world and you
know if the trumpets don't want to count
these little countries when it comes to
testing rate if we also don't count them
when it comes to death rate we have the
ninth highest death rate in the world
not exactly that low death rate here's
another video another protest I don't
even know what's happening in this one
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean it's it's it's reminiscent of
like that website WorldStarHipHop that
just posts fights between people it's
absolutely crazy what's going on and
that that's what we're dealing with and
you can rest assured that that will lead
that will lead to many many more cases
upcoming welcome to everybody who's
watching on YouTube make sure that you
have liked the stream and smashed that
subscribe button if you have questions
comments anything you want to have me
address send it via a super chat on
youtube it'll appear in that very
sad-looking gray box in the bottom left
we did get a super chat from Brody
Andrew Mulligan who says restaurants are
back open in Texas I am scared
we need like three or four of them
before they actually show up here but
Brody is here and he I would be scared
my I mean just avoid restaurants is what
I would probably advise also Rebecca
Carranza has subscribed over on YouTube
and I very much appreciate that YouTube
super chats I will be answering
questions there also want to say thanks
to a few folks over on Twitch vibes
fruit has just subscribed with twitch
Prime happy mcpeepers has just
subscribed as well and so has MS thumper
don't call her mrs. MS thumper has
subscribed on Twitch as well which is
very very exciting the latest official
numbers just to get caught up the global
case toll has surpassed 3.5 million the
real number is of course much higher we
are approaching a quarter million deaths
there were a lot of lunatic
right-wingers there's a dude named Bill
Mitchell who said let me know when this
thing kills 30,000 like the flu well
bill we're about 10 times past that
would love to hear from Bill a lot of
cases still being found 80,000 new cases
today 83 thousand new cases yesterday
and about 3400 deaths today the United
States numbers officially now
approaching 1.2 million official cases
the real number is probably between 4
and 24 real cases
we are at sixty eight thousand five
hundred and forty nine deaths officially
and you know the exact number is not
that also we are increasingly seeing of
course these very high population state
so you've got a couple things states
with very high populations and that are
in this New York New Jersey epicenter
have a lot of cases states with a lot of
testing so like here in Massachusetts
we're one of the top testing states and
we have a lot of direct flights to China
we have a lot of cases but then you were
also starting to see more and more new
cases in places like on a percentage
basis of Virginia
Virginia's numbers up you know six
percent today that's a lot for them
Florida which seems to be hiding deaths
as we reported to you last week they're
getting more cases Ohio getting more
cases Texas Michigan has had a lot of
cases from the beginning even Iowa now a
five percent increase in cases today
Tennessee a four percent so if all of
these places keep adding four to eight
percent every single day those will be
the epicenter soon Georgia by the way is
a fiasco Georgia is very very quickly
let's see what happened yesterday in
Georgia Georgia yesterday with another
eight hundred yeah Georgia which has
made a lot of has bragged a lot about
reopening an absolute and total fiasco
is a brewing in Georgia and I would I
would not expect that to turn around
anytime soon in things are improving
here in Massachusetts we have a
relatively low hospitalization rate and
the case growth rate has been declining
and it's down to about three percent so
hopefully in two weeks we're gonna be in
in okay shape a few other Super chats
coming in oh no oh so so first actually
over on twitch cynical insomniac has
just subscribed with prime Thank You
over on YouTube
Jeremy baat says keep up the good work
pacster unknown prodigy says what kind
of bike do you own mountain or Road I
have a hybrid or some might call it a
crossbreed or a mutt is what I call it
may Queen
sends a super chat tristan mcoppins says
I think with multiple extremely
irresponsible reopening 'he's Cova
deaths in the US could reach 1.8 million
what are your thoughts I don't know
anything that the mob you know I don't
know anymore than the models it's
conceivable you could have a number that
high it's conceivable Adrian
benningfield says hi David can you do an
interview with bow of the fifth column
he has some wonderful and useful ideas
he has prep list videos you alpha male
you I will check that out that's an
interesting idea
jay-ar says political language is
designed to make lies sound truthful and
murder respectable and to give an
appearance of solidity to pure wind
George Orwell I'm not familiar with that
quote but III believe you are telling me
the truth and it is particularly
relevant today I would say thanks to
folk u'b or subscribing on twitch and
you FK Kennard Darth Bane has also
subscribed and says hey did you see the
other sexual harassment claim against
Biden and that then was disproved in
under 24 hours I did not yeah you know
what so we for a while people were
saying David you're not talking about
Tara Reed enough we now have five and by
tomorrow we'll have six clips related to
terror on the YouTube channel now people
are angry because I'm saying the wrong
things about Tara Reed what we call this
as a disagreement you just disagree with
me that you I I'm not calling for Biden
to end his campaign Biden's winning
every poll candidates typically don't
end campaigns when they're winning every
poll you know it seems like we just
disagree it wasn't but people have to be
honest it wasn't just that they wanted
me to talk about it they wanted me to
talk about it and say exactly what you
believe and you know the craziest thing
the people saying I wasn't talking about
it enough we're being very loud but
every single clip about it on my youtube
channel gets like no views because most
of my audience doesn't seem to actually
be focused in on that story it's
incredible I mean listen what's been
reinforced is I just need to do the show
the way I want to do the show and the
way I've always done the show which
I talk about what I want to talk about
how I want to talk about in proportion
to how much I want to talk about it and
let the the sort of cards fall where
they may I think that's what we're
learning my friends okay other super
chats coming in Bryan Holaday says we
will always love Bernie for pushing us
all to the left how can we at this point
move forward and see his ideas become
legislation we need to have some other
folks push the ideas forward and I've
got a bunch of videos about that and
Burgos says Dave Anna Burgos David have
you heard a study saying a different
strain of the virus came from Europe to
the Northeast which could be why we
resembled numbers from the EU I heard
that but I don't know that to be true
so we'll see what what ends up happening
with that also thanks to Carrick the
drum tarek of the drum for the super o
for the assign up hana laura Clemmensen
says love your garden updates my garden
is the biggest ever this year calling it
my corona Victory Garden love the show
David thanks Hana Laura Constance Neil
says wasn't going to watch but excited
to see you react yeah I think this will
be interesting I think this will be
interesting there is going to be
propaganda until quarter past the hour
so we're just going to keep chatting
until until that point let me say an
incredibly sincere and massive thank you
to Christos and Catherine TVO's who are
I guess together our new member number
one today at join pakman.com and I also
want to say thanks to wait where did
this go Zanna Matthews Zanna Matthews is
new member number two today at join
pakman.com we very very sadly took some
hits in a p-- in March and April
we lost 722 paid subscribers because of
the virus I mean we know why it is
everybody's tightening the belt I get
that I am NOT a priority when people
have to pay rent and so on and so forth
get it but if you are in a position
where you can support the work that we
do please grab a membership at join
pakman.com everybody will get a huge
thank you from me live on stream we're
talking about two bucks a month if you
use that coupon code that coupon code is
illegal in some smaller countries its
grits too crazy of a coupon code but
we're allowing it here in the United
States if you use the coupon code 2020
now it's only two bucks a month and if
you pay for the year it's only a dollar
eighty a month so 722 people were still
here for you I get you had to cancel
because we all know what's going on but
thanks to the support of lots of new
folks who have signed up we hopefully
are going to be able to come close to
balancing that out and on that note
Lisa Pell toe is new member number three
today thanks Lisa
very much appreciate it later when we go
over to twitch when this starts then we
will we'll talk about twitch prime and
all of that nonsense let's see here
Sam Dean says get ADP fourteen hundred
and six cases in Victoria up twenty-two
from yesterday nineteen of them related
to the meat industry that's twenty two
cases from thirteen thousand tests
yesterday dad that's stunning
that is stunning Miguel Palacios says do
you think Gavin Newsom can be the new
face for the progressive movement in
2024 you know the problem is a lot of
people will say Gavin's not progressive
enough that there's going to be a lot of
litmus testing of Gavin I think he's an
interesting I mean a fantastic speaker
and you know transmits a degree of
competence that I mean you know this guy
that's on your screen does not but that
that is it's an interesting idea for
sure we will see what happens and people
are talking about Cuomo but then a lot
of people say Cuomo is not nearly
progressive enough he's basically you
know half a step to Biden's left so I
think there's going to be a lot of
fighting over who should be the people
pushing forward carrying forward for
lack of a better term the progressive
movement
let me say thanks to Constance Neal who
has just signed up on my website join
pakman.com and his new member number for
today Constance thank you so much I it's
been so inspiring really to see you know
I came to you guys and I said here we're
having this problem more than 700 people
had to cancel memberships because of the
virus and so many of you folks have
stepped up and so has Constance so has
Constance which I very much appreciate
JR says via super chat one more then
I'll shut up journalism is printing what
someone else does not want printed
everything else is public relations
George Orwell yes that's a quote I am
very familiar with very very familiar
with people are saying that I went to
Boston College for grad school no I did
not I taught at Boston College but I did
I went to Bentley University for
graduate school not Boston College okay
we are about 10 ish minutes from the
start of this Donald Trump virtual Town
Hall we will be switching over to only
Twitch closer to 7:15 for copyright
purposes okay so we'll be over at Twitch
starting at quarter past the hour at
twitch.tv slash David Pakman but for
them for the time being we are here let
me say thank you to Abela danger
official who says hey David I'm watching
your stream right now what are you up to
I'm doing the stream obviously also
thanks to Plague of the earth for
gifting to subscriptions tied well says
via super chat who would you consider
the most progressive governor in the
United States yes I don't know the
answer to that I'd have to think about
that the most progressive governor in
the United States I don't know I I would
I would have to think about that and
give you a more informed answer Pierre
Boudreau says hey David this is my
second try at making you say a few words
in pret in French please do or else I'll
going to end up broke trying to convince
you okay geez
Adrian Mendoza says I've been a
subscriber since 2011 I've always loved
your videos you were super sexy oh my
god how is your Oh
the co-host Lewis is fine Lewis is fine
he is he's participating in a lot of
elements of video gaming many many
elements of video gaming exciting ones
by the way big thank you to Derek Miller
Derek Miller is new member number five
today at join pakman.com also thanks to
tarik muhammad who is new member number
six at join pakman.com and Michael
Goldberg and Michael Goldberg is new
member number seven at join pakman.com
thanks Michael very much appreciate it
don't feel obligated to use that coupon
code it's available but you don't yeah I
mean pay full price by all means you
know whatever price you want to pay is
fine a CJ barber says I'm a conservative
and new to the channel but like
listening to your perspective and look
forward to seeing your conversations
with Republicans in the future a
beautiful message of bipartisan
tolerance I love it how about a like for
that make sure to LIKE the YouTube
stream if you like that message of peace
and love from CJ Barbour I love it
alright a conrad ami has subscribed on
twitch and we will be heading over to
twitch momentarily for the remainder of
the stream I think it's just safer from
from the standpoint of copyright from
look from the standpoint of copyright so
we'll be switching over to twitch.tv
momentarily couple other thank-yous here
Yuri Campos is new member number 8 at
join pakman.com Roxanne Brown hey
Roxanne Roxanne is number 9 I also want
to say thanks to Blair Harold Blair
Harrell is new member number 10 at join
pakman.com very much appreciate it and
we are expecting that this will be about
a 90 minute townhall total about 7:15 to
8:45 based on Donald Trump's schedule
for people wondering it should be about
a 90 minute 90 minute townhall starting
very very soon very very soon and I you
know I do expect a degree of lying and
propaganda that will be stunning but I
do you expect bret baier and martha
maccallum to play pho devil's advocate
so devil's advocate would be actually
challenging what trump says even if it's
only to get it on the record they're
gonna do faux devil's advocate where
they will be pretending to challenge but
with deliberately weak stuff that's my
prediction that's my prediction okay kay
smalls says thanks for your hard work
appreciate what you do people do not
realize how hard it is for all of us on
YouTube to actually give the real news
much love thank you I appreciate that
Brody Andrew Mulligan says can I get a
shout out to Candice Valenzuela endorsed
by Warren and the Progressive Caucus
facing off in Texas 24 congressional
primary runoff okay you got it I don't
know anything about that race but I am
willing to learn I'm willing to learn
for sure also a quick thank you to
Lorraine Cisneros who is new member
number 11 today at joined pakman.com on
that note we are just minutes from the
start of this town hall so i encourage
you to come on over to twitch at
twitch.tv slash david pakman it's a
whole new world if you're watching on
facebook or youtube right now you will
not believe the usernames the insanity
that can happen on Twitch but we have
moderators and we have everything it's
going to be a very very appropriate very
appropriate stream in every sense so in
a few minutes we will be going over
there and everybody with Amazon Prime by
the way if you go to twitch amazon.com
you can connect Amazon to twitch and
subscribe with prime on Twitch you pay
nothing nothing but we get a couple
bucks which is very very exciting quite
frankly LD says I'm trying to join but
got an error 8100 what I don't know I
don't know what what you mean I don't
know what you mean but folk the
memberships are rolling in fast and
furious so it appears to be working fine
looks like there's a seven people right
now in the process of signing up and
from what I'm looking at it's all
working swimmingly all working
swimmingly okay let me do a couple
thank-yous before we make the switch
Jeremy bought
Jeremie bot is new member number 12
today and Jed Lindley is new member
number 13 at join pakman.com and on that
note I am going to be pausing these
streams on YouTube and Facebook pausing
YouTube and Facebook the analysis of the
townhall it's all happening right now
literally right now at twitch dot TV
slash david pakman get the app on your
phone or just watch on your browser I'll
see you over there right now okay so
where the stream doesn't end come on
over twitch.tv slash Dave